[Musique]
les officiels inaugure la nouvelle
plate-forme associative d'aide aux
victimes pour les communes de l'Est un
espace dédié à l'accueil à l'écoute et à
l'aide aux personnes victimes de
violences sous toutes ses formes
novoland un thé à venir aussi auprès des
mairies des communes dans tout ce qui
est programme de prévention et il y a
les bailleurs sociaux qui sont aussi des
acteurs représente et pour ce qui
concerne le département et bien nous
avons une déléguée vice-présidente
délégué aux violences intrafamiliales
nous avons aussi les associations qui
réalise un travail considérable et donc
nous mettons encore plus de moyens pour
les accompagner pour faire que c'est
violence intrafamiliale
recul sur le territoire de la Réunion
l'espace pavillon situé à Bras-Panon
regroupe 3 association spécialisé Elsa
sur un soutien aux victimes ainsi que
leurs proches et facilite la
coordination avec les autres services
association qui s'appelle le réseau wifi
qui s'occupe de violence la familiale
global est dans un critère de grand
danger il y aura la rive qui est
l'antenne réunionnaise de l'Institut de
victimologie qui fait de la prise en
charge pour toute forme de violence et
il y a également la fille qui est une
association qui lutte et qui intervient
par rapport aux dérives sectaires et
donc c'est trois association vont se
mettre sous la forme d'une plate-forme
et cette plate-forme a donné lieu à de
l'accueil à des consultations a des
évaluations
également on aura des prises en charges
individuelles mais aussi groupale la
Réunion et le troisième département au
niveau national le plus touché par les
violences intrafamiliales
[Musique]